Transcriber: Dilara AL
Gözden geçirme: Esra Çakmak
Merhaba arkadaşlar, hepinizi
sevgiyle kucaklıyorum.
Bugün burada siz ile buluşmamızı sağlayan
Alara’ya teşekkür ederek
başlamak istiyorum.
Çok vakit kaybetmeden
direkt konuya gireceğim.
Sağ olsun arkadaşlar da beni tanıttı.
İkigai yaşam amacı.
Konumuz bu.
Sağ olsun bu davetle ben de kendi
yaşamımı gözden geçirmiş oldum.
Biraz metodize ettim.
Size bunlardan bahsedeceğim
aldığım notlardan.
İlk sorduğum soru, hayatta yaşama adım
atarken yaşamak sadece nefes almak mıdır?
Bence değil.
Yaşamak daha soyut bir kavram.
Hayatta olmaktan daha öte bir kavram.
Bir şekilde herkes bir şekilde hayatta
kalıyor, yemeğini yiyor.
Bunlar temel ihtiyaçlar
ama yaşamak böyle mi?
Ruhumuz bunlarla mı doyuyor?
Bu soru çok önemliydi benim için.
Sizin yaşlarınızdayken hayatın kendisine
kapılıp bir yerlerde savrulup giderken
derslere boğulmuşken,
birçok şeye boğulmuşken
çok düşünme fırsatım olmuyordu
kendi hakkımda.
Ama bir gün hayat öyle bir yol
ki bir şey yaşarsınız
ve bir anda sizi düşündürmeye başlar.
18 yaşımdayken bir kaza sonucu
tendonlarımı koparıp
ameliyattan uyandığımda
bir arkadaşım da gelip bana demedi,
“Şu dikişlerin birazını bana ver!” diye.
“Bu mümkün mü?” diye bir soru
sordum kendime ve o gün,
bir yere kadar insanların olduğunu ve bir
yerden sonra yalnız olduğumu anladım.
O gün aslında sorular sormaya başladım.
Ben ne yapıyorum?
İstediğim şeyler bunlar mı?
Bunlar beni mutlu ediyor mu?
Huzurlu muyum?
Kendimle barışık mıyım?
Bu çok önemli bir konu.
Kendimi seviyor muyum?
Bunları sorduktan sonra
düşünmeye başladım ufak ufak
ve hayatı daha başka izlemeye başladım.
Yapmak istemediğim,
yapmaya maruz kaldığım durumlar oldu
ve bunlar bana ne istemediğimi öğretti.
O kadar önemli bir nokta ki bu.
Hemen bir insan yaşam amacını bulamaz.
Bazı deneyimler size ne
istemediğinizi söyler.
Bu da ne istediğinizi, ne yapmaktan
hoşlandığınıza sizi götüren bir yoldur
ve yaşamaya böyle devam ettim.
Amaç aramaya başladığımda
sanırım 18-19 yaşındaydım.
Amaç aramak da
bugün görüyorum ki,
amacı bulmanın bir
parçası, yolun bir parçası.
Biraz sancılı bir süreç, acılı bir süreç.
Erdemin yolu akıldan geçer misali.
Ama değiyor.
Şunu da soruyorum kendime:
Bir amacı olmalı mı, yaşamanın?
Bence olmalı çünkü öyle mutlu oluyorum.
Belki olmayabilir başkaları için,
onlara da saygı duyuyorum.
Çok önemli bir durum var arkadaşlar.
Öyle bir dönemde yaşıyoruz ki
kendimizle baş başa kalmamız çok zor.
Çünkü en basitinden
tek başına kaldığımız yerde
cebimizde bütün dünyaya açılabileceğimiz,
bütün insanların ne yaptığını
görebileceğimiz
sosyal medya var, internet var.
Bir avantaj bu,
aynı zamanda bir dezavantaj.
Çünkü en sağlıklı cevaplar,
en sağlıklı sorular
insan kendiyle baş başa kalınca
soruluyor ve düşünülüyor.
Bunu da örneklemek istiyorum,
kendi yaşamımla.
Bu süreçte her gün
engel olamıyordum düşünmeye;
içim kararıyor, endişeleniyorum.
Soruyorum, ben ne yapacağım?
Ne olacak?
Sonra bir gün, şöyle bir şey oldu.
10 sene sonra ben nerede olmak istiyorum?
10 sene sonramı hayal ettim
ve o hayalin de bir hissi var,
hoşuma gitti o his
ve aklıma bir anda çocukluğum geldi.
Çocukken yaramaz ve hiperaktif
bir çocuktum.
Yuvada piyesler vardı ve
orada rol alıyordum.
Müthiş dinginleşiyordum.
İçimi huzur kaplıyordu.
O hissi hatırladım ve o an karar verdim.
Ben bu yoldan gideceğim.
Bunu tartmadan etmeden
çok hızlı bir karardı bu benim için
ve hemen eyleme döktüm bunu.
O zaman Marmara Üniversitesinde
okumaktaydım.
Turizm otelcilik bölümü de
hiç bana uyumayan bir bölümdü
ve bunun da farkındaydım.
Hemen oranın tiyatro bölümü
kulübüne gittim.
Hiçbir şey bilmiyordum.
Yetenekli miyim değil miyim?
Yapabilir miyim?
Bunların hepsinin cevabı bunu
deneyimledikten sonra geldi.
Biraz yapabildiğimi gördüm.
Hâlâ bana sorarsanız yetenek.
Bilmiyorum yani kelimeyi irdelediğimde
yetmekten gelen bir kelime.
Siz bir şeye yetebiliyor musunuz?
Sanırım böyle. Yetmek için
de çalışmak gerek.
Bir kitapta karşıma çıkmıştı,
10 bin saat kuralı.
Bir işte uzmanlaşmanın kuralı 10 bin saat.
Bu arada şunu da belirtmek isterim.
Meslekler hakkında konuşuyoruz.
Ben meslek olarak görmüyorum bu yaptığımı.
Benim varoluş nedenim.
Bu şekilde var oluyorum.
Bir oyuna prova yaparken
kendimi keşfediyorum.
Çok hoşuma gidiyor bu.
Bu başkasının gitmeyebilir,
başka bir şey olabilir.
Hepimizin içinde bir hazine
olduğunu düşünüyorum.
Ama hazinenin içinde
bambaşka şeyler olduğunu düşünüyorum
ve şu an bunu bulamamış insanların da
içinde de bu hazine var.
Sadece oraya gidip
o kendinizle gerektiği yerde kavga edip
kendinizle ilişki kurmaya başlayıp,
o kapıyı açma cesareti ile o kapıya
kapağını azminden açtığınızda
karşınıza gelen bir şey var.
Umarım bunu bulursunuz.
Bu da dediğim gibi
bazen istemediğinizi yaptığınızda,
ne istemediğinizi bula bula oluyor.
Hayat bir şekilde sizi
oraya yönlendiriyor.
Yeter ki hayatı dinleyin.
Bahsettiğim gibi bu düşüncede bunu
çözdüğünüzde bu iş bitmiyor.
Bir eylem süreci var.
Eyleme geçince de bitmiyor.
Yani bu yaşam amacı bir süreklilik,
bir süreç hâlâ devam ediyor.
Şu an 36 yaşındayım,
kaç yıl geçmiş üstünden.
Ancak 10 yıl sonrasını düşünüp
10 yıl geriye baktığımda,
evet kendimi gördüğüm yerdeyim.
Çünkü çok emek verdim.
Emek vermek o kadar önemli ki arkadaşlar.
Sevdiğiniz işe emek verin.
Sevdiğiniz işin ne olduğunun
çok bir önemi yok.
Neyi seviyorsanız başkalarına çok ters
gelen şeyleri de sevebilirsiniz.
Burada tabii ki çok önemli etik ve insan
olabilmek, bunu insanca yapabilmek,
saygı çerçevesinde yapabilmek.
Şunu görüyorum ki aslında emek verirken
varılmak istenen noktaya gidildiğinde
değil, oraya giderken insan öğreniyor.
Yolda öğreniyorsunuz.
Süreç size öğretiyor ve şunu
fark ediyor insan.
Öğrenmek çok keyifli.
Bu öğrenmekten kastım didaktik değil.
Yaşam size didaktik bilgi sunmuyor.
Böyle cümle cümle şeyler söylemiyor.
Bir şeyi yaşıyorsunuz,
bunun üzerine düşünüyorsunuz.
Bir deneyim elde ediyorsunuz.
Müthiş bir duygu benim için.
Bu yüzden prova yapmayı çok seviyorum.
Özellikle meslek için söyleyeyim.
Mesleğimiz sizin hayatınızın çok
büyük bir bölümünü kapsayacak.
O yüzden sevdiğiniz, belki hobiniz,
yapmaktan mutlu olduğunuz işi
meslek hâline çevirirseniz
bambaşka, iç içe girmiş gibi
olacak hayatınızda.
Para odaklı düşünmeyin.
Yani şu an benim gözlemlediğim, gençlerle
ettiğim sohbetler çok önemli benim için.
Keşke yüzyüze olsaydık, çok mutlu olurdum.
Para odaklı düşünülüyor,
çok para mutluluk getirir gibi
bir yanılsamalı bir cümle var.
Hayır, bir yere kadar mutluluk getirir.
Kendimizi keşfetmenin mutluluğu
hiçbir şeyde yok.
Bana sorarsanız.
Bir de zor kelimesini çok duyuyorum.
Ben bu yolu seçtiğimde zor
sözcüğünü çıkardım sözlüğümden.
Onun yerine “rağmen”i koydum.
Ama böyle demek yerine buna
rağmen demeyi seçtim.
Bu da,
ister istemez sizi bir
savaşçıya çeviriyor.
Çünkü hayat
her zaman pozitif, her zaman negatif,
çok karmaşık bir yapı.
Hayat size kendi bildiği gibi geliyor
ve siz hayatı kontrol edemezsiniz.
Ancak kendinizi kontrol edebilirsiniz.
Hayatın getirdiklerine uyumlanıp,
bunları kendi yararınıza,
kendi faydanıza çevirebilirsiniz.
Bahsettiğim şey manevi bir fayda.
Maddi bir fayda değil.
O yüzden zor sözcüğünü sözlüklerinizden
çıkarmaya davet ediyorum sizi.
Hayatınızın daha renkli olacağı kesin.
Gençliğin en büyük avantajı
önünüzde koskoca bir yol var.
Kontrol edilemez bir enerji var.
Siz amacı bulduğunuzda o enerjinizi
oraya yönlendiriyorsunuz.
Bu da çok keyifli ve dinginleşiyorsunuz.
Burada pozitif olmak veya negatif olmak
değil, kendinizle baş başa kaldığınızda
nötr bir yerden olabildiğince baktığınızda
o zaman sanki önümüzde
bir dere var, altı kum.
Yavaş yavaş duruluyor ve o gölün
o denizin dibini görmeye başlıyorsunuz.
Gölünüz daha berraklaşıyor.
Burada çok önemli bir durum var.
Paylaşmak, insan bir yere kadar
kendine dışarıdan bakabiliyor.
Dostlarınızla yaptığınız paylaşımlar
sizin kafanızda çok güzel kapılar açabilir
sizi düşünülebilir.
Kanlı canlı delikanlı dedikleri zaman
sadece bu cinsiyetçi bir kavram değil,
kadın için de erkek için de geçerli.
İnsanın kanı kaynar.
Bazen çok sağlıklı düşünemez.
Ama bu paylaşımlarda baktığınız zaman
o geniş yolu çerçevelendirmek
istediğiniz gibi sizin elinizde
ve bu paylaşımlar sizi düşündürecek.
Bir de çok güzel bir durumunuz var.
Saçmalama lüksünüz var.
Hata yapma lüksünüz var.
Yapın, korkmayın.
En büyük korku korkudan korkmak.
Hata yapmaktan korktuğunuz
zaman hep hata yaparsınız.
Baktığınız zaman kendi deneyimlerinize
bunu göreceksiniz.
Korkmayın, hata yapmaktan saçmalama
lüksünü kullanın.
Saçma sorular sorun.
Bazen çok saçma sorular, çok
büyük icatlara yol açar.
Kendinize emek vermek o kadar önemli ki
arkadaşlar siz kendinize emek vermezseniz
size insanlar bir yere kadar emek verecek.
Ama siz kendinize emek verdikçe, kendinize
oluşturmaya başladıkça
yaşadığınız duygular tarifsiz olacak.
Akşamları yatağınıza girdiğinizde
huzurla uyacaksınız.
15 saniye sürüyor benim uykuya dalmam.
Tabii buraya gelene kadar
bu mevsimler gibi
insanın içinin de mevsimleri var.
Bazen kış olacak, bazen yaz gelecek,
bazen bahar gelecek.
Bazen hiç bir şey olmayabilir olacak.
Burada önemli olan vazgeçmemek.
Ben mesela bunu kendime çok sordum,
dürüstçe “vazgeçeyim”.
İçim el vermedi.
Vazgeçsem, yapacak bir şey bulamadım.
Belki bulsam bu yoldan vazgeçebilirdim.
Bu yola girdiğiniz zaman yol size
ne yapmanız gerektiğini söylüyor.
Ne okumanız, neye çalışmanız,
bunu söylüyor yol size.
Yeter ki yolu dinleyin.
Bu yol sizin içinizde.
Bu içinizdeki yolu, bu hayalinizdeki
yolu dışarıya döndürdüğünüzde,
bu yol gerçekleşiyor.
Bu mucize değil de ne?
Her zaman insanların mucize
beklediğini gördüm.
Halbuki aynaya bakın.
Gözlerinizin içine bakın.
Birazcık mucizeyi göreceksiniz.
Dışarıdan değer beklemek.
Evet, herkes kendini değerli
hissetmek istiyor.
Şunu soruyorum.
Siz kendinize değer veriyor musunuz?
Kendinize değer verin.
Kavga edin kendinizle.
Barışın ama asla küsmeyin.
Kendinizden vazgeçmeyin arkadaşlar.
Kendinizden vazgeçtiğinizde
her şeyden vazgeçmiş olursunuz.
Bu çok önemli.
Çok kötü zamanlarınızda bile kendinizin,
içinizin, kalbinizin, içinizdeki çocuğun
elini bırakmayın.
Bazen dediğim gibi amaca giden yolda
istemediğiniz şeyler yaşayabilirsiniz.
Şöyle düşünmek lazım bu
uzun vadeli bir yol.
Bugün size 36 yaşındayım derken
zamanın gerçekten nasıl geçtiğini
algılamış değilim.
Bunu bana hep söylerlerdi.
Sizin yaşlarınızdayken ben algılayamazdım.
Sizin de algılayamama ihtimaliniz var.
Bir yıl çok büyük bir zaman
gibi görünüyor.
Ama bakın pandemi başlayalı, 1 yıl bitti.
Mart ayındayız.
Nasıl geldik bilmiyorum.
Özellikle böyle belirsiz dönemler
için geleceğe dair sorular sormak
sizi endişeye sokabilir.
Böyle durumlarda size tavsiyem gününüzü
doğru değerlendirmeniz.
Bugünü doğru değerlendirirseniz,
geleceğinizi doğru inşa edersiniz.
Bugün yaşadıklarınız
geçmişinizde aldığınız kararlar,
geçmişinizden getirdikleriniz,
O zaman bugün yaptıklarınız
da geleceğimiz olacak, arkadaşlar.
Size son sözüm.
Düşünceden eyleme geçip,
cesaret anahtarını kullanın.
Belirsizlik insanı korkutur.
Boşluk insanı korkutur fakat
bir yandan da çok iyidir, boşluk.
Her şeyi alabilecek,
algılayabilecek hâlinizdesinizdir.
Bu boşluğun rehavetine kapılmayıp,
bu boşluğun sizdeki güzelliğini fark etmek
ve bunun size heyecan vermesini sağlamak
sizi hayata daha fazla bağlayacaktır.
Umarım yolunuza
biraz ışık tutabilmişimdir.
Keşke yüz yüze olsaydık.
Sorular sorup diyalog yapsaydık.
Enteresan bir durum bu,
bilgisayar ekranında sadece insanın
kendini görerek izlemesi.
Daha ulaşamadım açıkçası.
Biraz sürreal bir dönem.
Umarım bir gün karşılaşırız ve sizler
hayat gayenizi, hayat amacınızı bulmuş,
kendiyle barışık, neşeli ve etrafa
neşe saçan insanlar olursunuz.
Hepinizi çok öpüyorum, teşekkür ediyorum.